lately we've been hearing that
unemployment's like at a record low
which is a good thing for the economy
but I just got done looking deep into
unemployment for this video we made and
my big takeaway is unemployment is
actually like not super well understood
I think most people think of
unemployment as like the number of
people who don't work that's like the
rate that they give like three percent
or whatever but it's actually slightly
more nuanced than that it's not everyone
in the economy who can't find a job it's
actually the number of people who want a
job who are like out looking for a job
who can't find a job there are a lot of
jobs in the economy that aren't counted
because they don't like pay money so
like people who care for other people
like parents or something they don't
count in the unemployment figure it's
only people who are out there looking
for jobs that make money and what it
doesn't capture is people who are
overqualified for their jobs like
someone who studied like to be a
pharmacist but can't find a job in being
a pharmacist and so they like teach
tennis lessons or something they're
technically employed but they're
underemployed